covet pandemic has presented a number of
challenges
including postponing weddings a positive
trend is emerging
yeah that's right brian more couples are
choosing to put a ring on it
arko mana explains why well she had no
idea
a pandemic proposal in the age of
covid19
efrain sanchez and alexa ferrick getting
engaged during an august hike at red
rock canyon
i turned around and kneeled down to one
knee pulled out the ring
and she was very surprised endless time
spent together during quarantine
sealing the deal i think that only
solidified the fact that
this is my person and he's who i want to
be with i think it really strengthen our
relationship
and they're not alone many engagements
have happened recently and it's
impacting certain industries
data shows after taking a dive at the
beginning of the pandemic jewelry sales
since
june are rising compared to last year
among the hot ticket items
are engagement rings something some las
vegas jewelry stores are noticing
love knows no pandemic huntington
jewelers has sold dozens of engagement
rings in just the past few months
each band representing a daring decision
it's a seize the day mentality
it's why wait you know what life is
really short and
if you love somebody go for it and some
local photographers are doing more
engagement shoots during covid than they
predicted
this has blown my mind in what's
happened to be honest we were prepared
to possibly not work into 2021
2022. on the flip side some couples fed
up with each other in quarantine have
split up but that means returning their
rings
it's been a huge business of ours to
actually
yes buy back efren and alexa consider
themselves lucky and while they wait for
their
dream wedding at disneyland they're
getting legally married later this month
it just changed the plans a little bit
definitely a sign of the times
orca mana 8 news now orco thank you
local jewelers tell us they're expecting
engagement ring sales to jump
even more this month but that's pretty
typical with it being of course the
holiday season